this kind of question comes up all the
time and this power here
five is about as well five six is about
where it tops out for
what you're expected to just know
without having to refer to a calculator
and say okay what are these coefficients
again the fifth row is not too bad the
fitter is not too bad
it's gonna have because to power five
how many terms are in that row of
pascal's triangle it'll be
six right so you can sort of think to
yourself oh it's gonna be this one
because it's got six terms right it'll
be perfectly symmetrical so there's no
just it's okay just leave it um there's
going to be no
middle middle term so if you have
coefficients there
i find it really helpful just for me to
always write it off on the side
first before i dive into the question
okay the reason why
is because this is this is pretty simple
okay this is pretty simple
but i can very easily make it hard
enough that it's
gonna become confusing if i gave you
something like this which
you'll see all the time okay you'll
start to get confused between
the twos and the threes and the power
you're raising them to
and the coefficients that they're all
being multiplied by okay so having them
out there on the side before you start
any working is very very helpful
so you don't mix them all up all right
now
bean and we've got a nice it's a one
plus x
type format right it's really nice you
don't have to worry about the one
you just have to worry about the x which
in this case is root three okay
so what's this going to be equal to i'm
going to think about my
coefficients and i'm going to bring the
power of x up as i go
so i'm going to begin with 1 and then
the next coefficient is 5
and i'll have x to the power of one
which is just in this case
root three now i could go ahead and
start simplifying when i get to the next
one
the next part will be root three q
squared sorry and i could just write
that down as three
i'm going to resist doing that for this
first line
because it's a little bit like a
substitution into a formula right and if
you're substituting into a formula you
just want to do that first
and then do all the simplifying later
right all the things you want to do
across one line
try not to confuse different steps with
each other so there's the third term
the fourth term again i can write that
simpler but i'm going to wait until i've
substituted everything
it'll help to keep the pattern in my
brain a little clearer as well this will
be
the penultimate term and there's
the last one happy there's my six terms
you can count all out one five ten ten
five what
haven't missed anything now i can
simplify out
the square roots okay so the one the
five root three they're going to stay
put
and then here i'm gonna have 10 by three
thirty
okay here i'm gonna have 10 by three
root three
right so thirty two three here i'm going
to have five
by five by nine
right
sorry forty well five by nine i'm just
gonna leave that
plus
okay i still have to do another line
anyhow so i'm not all that fussed about
it
now i've got all my third components and
then i've got all my
rational components right so i've got a
1 31
45 that's 76. yes
76. how many rational terms do i have
i've got five root three
thirty five root three forty four
forty four rupee okay there you go
and i've just almost answered the
question the actual question was
what are a and b so therefore i can say
a 76
b is 44 and i'm finished that's it
that's all you have to do
okay so be patient with it if you
were to get a question with a higher
power right
or something else which requires a
different approach i'll show you how to
do that afterwards but
the number this more you can actually
just machine it out it's not that hard
okay